so I was just saying it was a great
pleasure for me to welcome the first
female president of the European Union
Commission this shows for her first
visit to a trip outside Europe for her
to come to the chipiya which is the
sitter's of the African Union speaks
volume of the commitment of the new
Commission towards try to lay this
relationship but most of all I want to
say that we're very happy to see that
the European and European Union on the
right side of history given giving women
their do given to women their place
their space so I think this is a very
good start very encouraging one and we
have promised that we'll work together
because then the ratio is universal and
we have to work all of us how we can
advance that thank you very much thank
you madam president for receiving me
today and sharing in time and experience
with me
indeed it is for me a privilege and an
honor to be here with the only head of
state in Africa that is a woman an
outstanding one impressive
biography and track record but I could
by myself
that you have a vast experience on
gender issues and then empowering women
I like very much the small part of
anecdote we shared that you grew up in a
family where you were taught that girls
and women can do anything and it's the
personality shows that and also the way
you act here as a president I highly
appreciate the experience you had with
powering women and programs you're
promoting here that you said that we
will share this experience I want to
learn for you whether the targeted
instruments you have to empower women
what mistakes were there what we should
avoid but also what worked and where we
can proceed together and to make a
difference you are an outstanding role
model and I realized that for young
girls and women and Ethiopia it must be
a wonderful encouragement to see you at
this place so thank you again for
sharing your time thank you